oh I'm back okay one back come back come
back let me call Rishi again let me call
me she let me call Rishi ok let's see if
it's working come on Rishi hello hello I
got disconnected got this companion at
what point did I was I just talking
talking talking at what point did I know
it was the whole question I missed the
whole but like I gotta kill and then
adjust my computer like the internet
went down oh man I we're on a roll we
were on a roll anyway it looks like
always the one that's that's may get
frustrating anyway we're good we're good
we good we good so the game is one that
that game or you're still on that game
no I'm still on that game but they had
to play without me for a while oh ok ok
gotcha ok question ok probably I'm
stressed I don't even know how the game
is going now here we go okay yes yes so
Lucas uh Luke an author Luke mm-hmm and
so this is a question about whether he
should get a traditional public
publisher or self-published he's
wondering if you know of really if
there's been really any truly successful
self publishers because he really wants
to I think avoid some of the things that
come with being with a traditional
publisher but once you gonna get your
feedback and and yeah shout out to your
one word in three launch right now with
evan evans book if you guys have gotten
it yet awesome and so I was just going
into all of my excitement about writing
my first book of it
oh we got oh wait look no i'm not but i
can't wait till i do i'm really excited
about actually one day writing book like
I feel like eventually that will be
something that I really want to do but
so I have not gone through the process
of writing a book but I you just in
general for those of you who might be
interested in knowing some of the main
kind of benefits of self-publishing I
know is that you have much more you know
control over story and like the platform
like this Lucan saying that he really
wants to be able to distribute the book
everywhere see how much more control
over that you you can write it in your
own timeline you don't have the
deadlines in the same way that you would
with the traditional publishers the
royalties are going to be higher and so
you know I and I guess all of the the
conventional wisdom says that whether
you self-publish for go with the
traditional publish publisher if the
book is great it's going to do well so
I'll make you know make sure that what
you're the whatever we decide to go that
the book is something that you really
believe in yourself and our providing as
much value as you can make the book
great just like we said make that great
make the the products for the east or
you shop great it all comes down to you
know this simple something that is
something that you're really proud of
but maybe then you could talk a little
bit more about even though you have how
many how many episodes do you have about
your book writing now at this point you
know that's a lot yeah it's a lot mm-hmm
I don't remember but it's a lot I got my
face yeah what do you think about um
yeah so you know for me it depends on
what you what success means to you
there's a number of reasons why you want
to
with a publisher versus going
self-publishing um but depends on what
your goals are so fur like if you want
to make a lot of money then you're gonna
make more money being self-published
than going with the publishers yeah
that's just this twisted fate is
bothering me my teammate is not being a
good teammate not i'm not a fan of this
teammate this so-called teammate of mine
here um anyway let me get this yes good
good job Jay rises doing work um so if
your goal is just to make money then
then then don't go through traditional
publisher because you're going to get
killed on on royalties and just in
general this the system is set up oh we
gotta kill nice yeah the system is set
up so that it it really hurts um hurts
he was a as an author to go with a
traditional publisher again if that
goals just revenue I just gotta kill we
had a pretty intense teamfight there so
I'm pretty excited about that I white
with a traditional publisher and if you
haven't if you're having questions about
writing a book and what you should do i
do i do recommend going out and checking
out the book series because I cover my
path of right in the book and the you
know ups and downs and and happiness in
struggles that I deal with in dealing
with a major publisher I went with a
major publisher because I wanted to get
the reach and I just felt like I would
get more reach with a major than only
trying to do my thing I would make more
money doing it myself but I'd get more
reach going with a major and that's my
goal like my goal was to have impact it
wasn't just to make money I wanted to
have impact right so again depending on
what your goal is is there's options for
you there are increasingly authors like
the questions can I have
SAS if if I'm not with a publisher yes
there's a lot of authors who are only
going with with their own self
publishing methods like I was I had
James Altucher on the channel you love
him hes to choose yourself guy had him
on the gym you know a couple weeks ago
and he has new york times bestselling
books and he's gone with a major
publishers and his books are are like
years old and still selling really well
uh whoa this is a crazy funny but but
now he's now he wants to go um so
publish so you get you get you know you
have way more options you get less less
restriction way more freedom when you
when you sell publish and that's you
know and I guess making my money to list
all of all the above is why do you want
it to do it and you know that's okay so
it just depends on what your what your
goal is there are lots of people who
have self-published there's lots of guys
as lots of you know blog pose as lots of
people have gone through the process and
they've shared their wisdom and
expertise so yes you can do it and I
think increasingly more people are doing
it I think a combination because of the
money and because of just wanting to
have the control you know my next book
depend on which 1i have two books in
mind ah I would not be able to do one of
them with a publisher because of the
restrictions that they have like just
from dealing with them on the book that
I have now I know that I would not be
able to deal with them on this other
book that I had in mind so depending on
what I do we will see so yeah I'm check
out the country's you'll learn a lot so
yeah you've got an upcoming book for me
a second one ah oui she's gonna have her
own book to talking about her ownership
and snapchat yeah lots to look forward
to yeah
well um so like did you feel I know this
I know the answer to this but just for
those who may not know like how much did
you have to give up of your
quote-unquote storyline because you know
the controls the story because you were
publisher with it it was a more than you
expected less than you expected ah I
want to say it was probably more than I
expected um didn't know what to expect
but it wasn't it wasn't that much you
know like as much as I may have
complained and you know made video
everybody like at the end of the day
like I got for the most part what I
wanted which is great ah but it fits
with what what this book is all about
like my next book at least the ideas for
one of the books it wouldn't it wouldn't
be possible like they would never they
would never agree like they would I
don't know I don't know if they would
even want to sign up for just too many
issues uh yeah so it's an old industry
they have really restrictive ways of
doing things I know you can work within
them for the purpose of your book then
that's awesome and if you can't then you
may need to consider going on your own
but but there are tons of people who are
doing it on their own and having lots of
success with so I wouldn't let that a
reason for you not to feel like you can
achieve success in your own yep okay
great have the game on I'm about to get
a kill so I'm excited about that oh
maybe not oh crap oh I'm gonna get a
double double kill give it to me oh I
got act oh I'm gonna die
oh alright i died i got greedy I got you
a degree she sometimes can you get ready
and pay the price that's what just
happened there I got greedy and I paid
the price but the game hey are we are
ahead I have five kills and two deaths
so even with my disconnection there
we're doing we're doing well gri hard
carrying us yeah he's doing well so yes
good we're doing well we're exciting I'm
dead right okay I'm focused okay um next
question comes from nibsy and nilsa
actually is a young mother young single
mother and she has a 17 year old son and
basically has a lot of just struggled
academically and but also is very gifted
artistically so some of the things that
he's interested in is cartoon he wants
to be a cartoonist and a web designer
but anyway she do justice feeling a
little helpless because she really he
knows that he needs guidance or some of
the struggles that he has and where she
lived she doesn't feel like they have
the resources that are you know enough
to meet his needs and so you just
decided to kind of ask for your thoughts
because she really wants to help her son
she wants to give him the best to be
able to pursue his dream and it just
doesn't know what to do next because it
sounds like there really isn't a lot
where they live so um yeah so I guess
for me a couple things come to mind she
did mention that they kind of go-between
mozambique and South Africa and so
obviously I don't live there don't never
been there so I wish I could be more
helpful in terms of guiding you to
helpful services and things where you
are what I can tell you is that I'm
familiar with a organization called iris
and iris is a global organization that's
actually located in both Mozambique and
in South Africa and they have a lot of
services for children young adults of
two adults so just on a practical level
for some help if you're seeking help
directly in your area for your son you
may want to check out iris glow bowl and
yeah maybe there's some at least someone
or something there that could could help
and then the other thing you know I
thought of is syphilis specifically in
terms of attending a passionate about
cartoonist and web design you know
there's you can find just about anything
on YouTube and I I bet there's tons of
cartoonist and just all kinds of
information that you could probably find
for him on youtube and I just if you
know about Evans channel that i'm
assuming than you have access to all of
the possible other YouTube channels that
might be able to help with his love for
for drawing and for web design and all
of those things and that's all I got I
love it um so I love this and I'm
feeling the motherly love and you know
they're there isn't there isn't
something that the mother wouldn't do to
help their kid you know learn and get
better and so I
thank you for for writing in and caring
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh this is
danger zone here can we do it I don't
think so oh we got the dough no jr. he's
cleaned it up all right good job good
job I died Jerry's got a kill um I feel
like I would have killed him though
anyway but it's all good I'm good I'm
glad you're risking um I think back to
when I was when I was in my first
venture growing up it was like baseball
cards i love doing baseball cards and
even though my parents had no idea about
baseball cards they still tried to help
me and took me to baseball card shows
and I'm sitting there like you know 12
years old negotiating with 40 50 year
olds over baseball cards and literally
nickel-and-diming them and say like can
you give me five cents huh Wow holding
my negotiation skills on you know 25
cent baseball cards that I would get
down to ten cents is awesome
eleven-year-old 12 year old charm um and
you know again they had no idea what
what I was doing what it was all about
but they could see the passion and so
they wanted to help me and so like I
remember that really helped me on my
path I agree with Rishi in that you are
part of a much larger community now like
you have YouTube man i wish i had
youtube growing up the things that that
i would have learned by using that
platform and when i think of this
problem i think of julius llego who is a
javelin thrower and I believe he became
the world champion and he's based out in
Africa I want to say Kenya but I could
be wrong and he taught himself to
javelin all from YouTube like he became
the world champion
javelin thrower oh oh I'm being attacked
because of YouTube and so they called
him mr. you too but if you look up mr.
YouTube you'll find him i did a video on
him not that long ago when in its press
oh uh and he had like nobody around him
who believed in him he didn't have
support and he just started analyzing
their technique he had no coach you know
he just started looking at how they were
doing it and said you know what I want
to try to do the same and he copied that
when he got better and he started
winning tournaments in Africa and then
he started competing on the global stage
and he started winning there too and so
you can learn a lot just from youtube if
you can put in the work and and the good
thing about it is he's got you like he
doesn't need the oh my team is all dead
my team is dead he doesn't need the he
doesn't need the coach like can I help
sure but you know what his God he's got
you and if you sit there and help him
and go through the videos with him and
show your love and support and help him
find videos and encourage him when
nobody else believes in him that's great
and that's all you need to do to start
and yes you know there may not be the
same opportunities that there are here
there may not be as many organizations I
mean you can check out the one we she
recommended but there may not be tons of
organizations for you that put it on
programs but don't let that don't let
that stop you don't let that be the
reason why you don't go out in and don't
continue to chase that dream for him
it's so easy to say well I come from
here and so I'll never be successful
we're really oh I died um we're really
it's about it's about resourcefulness is
about entrepreneurship it's about doing
the thing that you know finding a way
through um
and so you know the way my parents did
it was they took me to baseball card
shows and we drove like you know why
went every year to our to to Florida
because spring training was there and
because I wanted to meet all the Blue
Jay players and I would go to their
parking lot and I would know who the
players were when they were driving in
and I would sit there and get autographs
oh we did that every year when I was
growing and so my parents again didn't
understand the passion but knew that I
was passionate about it wanted to
encourage me to keep going so I I have
no doubt that if if my parents were in
that situation that's what they would be
doing is they would be trying to find
YouTube videos to help me learn to look
at coaching programs that are free
online with the some there's so many
people who do drawing videos now online
ton is it that you can learn a lot from
that that are probably better than what
you would learn from a local person
anyway yeah I'm 22 and so I've no doubt
that my parents now if they were in
Africa we were switching spots that's
what they would do and that's what I
would do and that's what I still do
right I want to learn from I want to
learn from world leaders I want to learn
from successful entrepreneurs I want to
learn people who've done it more than me
and and I don't know how to do that
locally I don't have anybody than I can
talk to and do it locally with and so I
get that by going on YouTube and and
that's why i started my channel
everybody on my team died except for me
and j reyez so we'll have to carry this
uh so yeah I mean I still do it I think
it's insanely powerful I think I think
that's what I would do and look up
Julius llego as an example of a guy who
was you know came from Africa and
basically just started on YouTube and
and you know became a world champion and
so your son I'm a world champion
at what he's doing if you if you give
him a little bit of belief and
confidence and help guide him by finding
resources and just being a supportive
voice the committee huge difference love
it I'm looking at videos now Julius
llego never heard them until today you
know I didn't either and then ivan was
on my team was researching videos and he
found it he's like I love this story can
we use it as an interested him you
should all of our videos are requests
nobody i donated him but hmm but i agree
i love the store this is amazing we have
to find a way to use it and yeah I'm
excited Julia's here you go who knew mr.
YouTube there's gonna be more to like
he's only the first people look at you
know Mark Zuckerberg now and the success
he had this Facebook and that inspires a
whole generation people to not want to
become entrepreneurs like Julius is just
the start of what's going to be coming
of people who learn in st. like how much
have people learned from my youtube
channel you know not like that not that
you know I know I'll tell my youtube
channel a little bit i'm not necessarily
saying i have the greatest youtube
channel in the world i do believe it's
pretty good though uh I what I do uh I
think we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna win just go fit yes GG we won
again hey the street continues nice I I
really think we've never lost I don't
know you may I feel like we have but
it's I don't know maybe not it's close
hey it's Benson you were talking about
your channel you can love your channel
even with me disconnecting and being out
of the game we're staying still we still
pull through that was a rough one that
was a rough one connection timeout I got
I got the best scorer team I love it um
yeah so so you know the resource you
have the resources the resources are
there the whole YouTube go out instead
and you've heard your son and help him
when he's down and help nobody believes
in him being out in the work that he's
putting together and just show your
support and that that's what he needs
and I'm excited and I'm excited and you
know that love is special the mother
cell of the special show i'm curious i
want to see you know what I want to see
one of his artworks do I'm gonna watch a
video and then send in weather isn't of
art so we can show it off I want to see
it oh I love that that's awesome all
right and any nice yeah I know you're
about to wrap up Evan but just to your
point I know this is really truly just a
genuine plug of your channel like when
I'm watching your channel I'm amazed by
the kind of information that is
available to people right here right now
for free like there really is no excuse
like it's insane I just sometimes I'm
watching it and I'm going Wow like if
people want to be successful it's all
just right here available and I'm just
it's just amazing to me that how much is
at people fingertips if you're really
hungry for one hundred percent it's
never been easier and there's never been
fewer restrictions and there's and
there's no reason to have an excuse to
say you don't have access to mentors or
information because it's there it's
there you just gotta do seem wait and do
the work alright alright well thank you
we she where can people find you if they
want more Rishi love more refuel of can
be found at reaching MCV place for good
music good food and get top intersect
what's in your cup I love it well thank
you guys for watching thank you Rishi
for co-hosting Thank You Jay rise for
being in the game we'll see you guys
again on Friday morning continue to
believe or whatever your one word is no
see you soon